The dos and don'ts of savvy airfare shoppers.
Do start shopping about four months before departure.
That's when the airlines start releasing the cheapest seats.
But don't buy all your family's tickets in a single transaction.
Airline reservation systems...
...require everyone on the same booking to fly at the same price.
So split your booking and you may find cheaper individual fares.
Do check on connecting flights.
They're starting to get a lot cheaper than those pricey nonstops.
Don't take flights with connections that are too tight.
Have at least one hour between flights...
...and make that two hours in the winter time.
Do set up flight status alerts for your cellphone...
...and those that are picking you up.
It'll save you a big hassle.